From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A few years ago, Emily Balchetes was fresh out of space in her life. She was overseeing an enormous research project. Her son was just a few months old and barely sleeping. And she had the opportunity to write a book. If Emily's life had been a hotel, it would have had a no vacancy sign out front. And that's when I decided, you know what? I also need to become a drummer.
我是NPR的Shankar Vedantam，这里是《Hidden Brain》。几年前，Emily Balchetes的生活几乎没有空隙。她当时负责一个庞大的研究项目，儿子才几个月大，几乎没法睡觉，而且她还有机会写一本书。如果Emily的生活是一家酒店，门外肯定挂着“客满”的牌子。就在那时，我决定，你知道吗？我也需要成为一名鼓手。
I needed something that was just for myself. I needed to explicitly and intentionally carve out time to let my own brain do the thing that it wanted to do just for me. Emily decided she'd learn to play a single song. I wanted to play one rock tune on drums but like really learn how to nail it. But might seem like a modest goal, but besides being short on time, Emily had another thing working against her. Playing drums is like patting your head and rubbing
我需要一些完全属于我自己的东西。我需要明确且刻意地挤出时间，让我的大脑做它想做的事，仅仅是为了我。Emily决定她要学会演奏一首歌。我想在鼓上演奏一首摇滚乐，但要真正学会如何完美地演绎它。这看起来可能是一个谦虚的目标，但除了时间紧迫之外，Emily还有另一个不利因素。打鼓就像一边拍头，一边揉
your stomach at the same time. You have to strike different drums at the right moment and use one foot to hit a pedal. Such coordination was not Emily's strong suit. I'm very uncoordinated. I have been my entire life. In the fourth grade, I was on a basketball team and I pushed my own teammate out of bounds when she was carrying the basketball
肚子一样。你必须在正确的时刻敲击不同的鼓，并用一只脚踩踏板。这种协调性并不是Emily的强项。我非常不协调。我这辈子一直都是这样。四年级时，我在篮球队，当队友运球时，我竟然把她推到了界外，
because I tripped on my own feet. I wasn't invited back to the next season of play. So coordination wasn't my forte. She chose the song Your Love by the English band The Outfield. And recorded herself what she practiced. Her early efforts sounded a bit like the person in the audience who claps on the wrong beat. Emily may not have been born with a gift of coordinated limbs, but what she did have was a mental encyclopedia of psychological insights. Emily drew on her years of studying psychology to help her practice. The research she put to use was not about sound,
因为我被自己的脚绊倒了。我没被邀请参加下一个赛季的比赛。所以协调性不是我的强项。她选择了英国乐队The Outfield的歌曲《Your Love》，并录下了自己练习的过程。她早期的努力听起来有点像观众席上拍子拍错的人。Emily可能天生没有协调肢体的天赋，但她拥有心理学见解的心理百科全书。Emily利用她多年的心理学研究来帮助自己练习。她所运用的研究不是关于声音的，
but about sight. A hidden secret about goal pursuit is that what we see is really tied to what we think, what we decide and what we do. This week on Hidden Brain, how we can use the Brain's visual system to shape our behavior. It's part of YouTube.0, our annual summer series about facing life's chaos with wisdom. When most of us think of the world around us, we think about what we see. Many people say the sense of sight is their most important sense and the one they most fear losing. My guest today says what we see affects more than just what we see. It also affects how we behave.
而是关于视觉的。关于目标追求的一个隐藏秘密是，我们所看到的与我们的想法、决定和行为息息相关。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将探讨如何利用大脑的视觉系统来塑造我们的行为。这是我们年度夏季系列节目“YouTube.0”的一部分，旨在探讨如何以智慧面对生活的混乱。当我们大多数人想到周围的世界时，我们想到的是我们所看到的。许多人说视觉是他们最重要的感官，也是他们最害怕失去的感官。我今天的嘉宾说，我们所看到的不仅仅影响我们所看到的。它还影响我们的行为方式。
Psychologist Emily Balcheras at New York University is the author of Clearer Closer Better. How successful people see the world. She studies the psychological dimensions of sight and says there are ways to exploit the brain's visual system to boost motivation, achieve goals, and gain perspective. By reimagining the frame around the problem, she says, we can literally see the world in a new way. Emily Bolchett is welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, pleasure to be here.
纽约大学的心理学家Emily Balcheras是《更清晰、更近、更好：成功人士如何看待世界》一书的作者。她研究视觉的心理维度，并表示有办法利用大脑的视觉系统来提高动力、实现目标并获得视角。她说，通过重新构想问题周围的框架，我们可以真正以一种新的方式看待世界。欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》，Emily Bolchett。你好，很高兴来到这里。
I want to start by having you tell me the story of a skydiver named Luke Aikens. You spoke with a fellow skydiver of his who says he gave Luke the species of advice. White, you're all right, red, and you're dead. What happened, Emily? This was an incredible story story a real amazing adventure. There were a team of sky divers who were trying to do the impossible. They were going to jump out of a plane at 25,000 feet. That's actually an elevation where sky divers need to use oxygen tanks to
我想从让你讲讲跳伞运动员Luke Aikens的故事开始。你采访过他的一位跳伞同伴，他说他给了Luke那种建议：白色，你没问题；红色，你就死定了。发生了什么，Emily？这是一个令人难以置信的故事，一场真正了不起的冒险。有一队跳伞运动员试图完成不可能的任务。他们打算在25000英尺的高空跳出飞机。那实际上是跳伞运动员需要使用氧气瓶来
sustain their breathing. They were going to jump out of that airplane and land in a net on the ground, but jump without a parachute. They took these incredible light bulbs, ones that are used to help airplanes land, in fact, that are sort of divided like a candy cane almost. Half of the light bulb is white color, the natural light coming through, and the other half is red. They took those lights that are normally sort of positioned just slightly at an angle to help guide airplanes to the right pitch as they're landing on a runway and instead pointed them straight up into the sky. So that as these
维持呼吸的高度。他们打算跳出那架飞机并降落在地面上的一个网里，但跳的时候不带降落伞。他们使用了那些令人难以置信的灯泡，就是用来帮助飞机降落的那种，事实上，它们的设计就像拐杖糖一样。灯泡的一半是白色的，是自然光透过的颜色，另一半是红色的。他们把那些通常稍微倾斜放置以帮助飞机在降落跑道时找到正确俯仰角的灯，改成了直指天空。这样，当这些
parachute as well non-parashoot jumpers were jumping out of a plane, they'd be able to find this array of lights shining, sort of illuminating, almost circling around this net that they were hoping to land in. They had positioned the red on the outside, in the white, on the inside. And what Luke Aikens was looking for was that space of white, and that's what he was searching for. He jumped out of this airplane. Jumpers are away, jumpers are they off? He was looking for that beacon of white.
非降落伞跳伞者跳出飞机时，他们就能找到这排闪烁的灯光，照亮并环绕着他们希望降落的网。他们把红色放在外面，白色放在里面。Luke Aikens寻找的就是那片白色空间，那就是他正在寻找的东西。他跳出了飞机。跳伞者准备好了吗？跳伞者出发了吗？他正在寻找那道白色的灯塔。
And that's where he knew that he would find his safety net. As he jumped out of the plane, of course he could see the mountains on the side. He could see the rivers snaking around through and he was scanning and scanning for that beacon of white light. And when he found it, that's all he focused on. Was that white light? That to him was what was the key here, that this narrowed focus, intense focus of attention concentrated on the white light is what led to him being able to do what was probably otherwise impossible for most people to jump out of that airplane without a parachute and find that small needle in a haystack,
那就是他知道自己能找到安全网的地方。当他跳出飞机时，当然他能看到侧面的山脉。他能看到蜿蜒的河流，他一直在扫描，寻找那道白色的灯光。当他找到它时，他所关注的全部就是那道白光。对他来说，这就是关键所在，这种狭窄的、集中的注意力集中在白光上，使他能够完成对大多数人来说可能是不可能的事情：在没有降落伞的情况下跳出飞机，并在大海捞针般的情况下找到那根针，
that small net in the middle of a vast expansive space. He's in! There's a less crazy story you're telling your book, less crazy in the sense that I'm not sure how many people would actually be willing to jump out of a plane at 25,000 feet without a parachute aiming for a speck on the ground and hoping to land on the snet. The less crazy story has to do with a marathon runner, Joan Benoit Simulson, who employs a similar technique at much, in some ways, much lower stakes. What is her strategy as she runs races? Well, she's amazing, because she's
在广阔的空间中间找到那个小网。他进去了！你在书中讲了一个不那么疯狂的故事，说它不那么疯狂是因为我不确定有多少人真的愿意在没有降落伞的情况下从25000英尺的高空跳下，瞄准地面上的一个点并希望落在那个网上。那个不那么疯狂的故事与马拉松运动员Joan Benoit Simulson有关，她在某种程度上使用了类似的技巧，但风险要小得多。她在跑步比赛时的策略是什么？嗯，她很了不起，因为她是
one of the most incredible female athletes of her time. Benoit won the gold medal for the first ever Olympic marathon for women. 45 miles, she had put so much pavement between herself and fights the number two runner that by the time Benoit entered the Coliseum she was all alone for the final lap and a half. She went on to win a dozen or so marathons and when asked
她那个时代最不可思议的女运动员之一。Benoit赢得了首届奥运会女子马拉松的金牌。45英里，她与第二名选手之间拉开了巨大的距离，以至于当Benoit进入体育场时，她在最后的一圈半里是独自一人。她后来赢得了十几场马拉松比赛，当被问及
what do you do what's your special secret power she said what she does is use that same kind of narrowed focus. She chooses a target ahead of her. It might be the pink shorts of somebody who's running up ahead or it might be a visual beacon that she can see up in the distance and she narrows her attention. Again, like a spotlight is shining just on that target that she's selected as if she's putting on blinders to anything that's around her and she hones in on that target until she reaches it and passes it, passes that competitor or passes that mark and then she sets the next goal for herself and focuses
你有什么特别的秘密武器时，她说她所做的是使用那种同样的狭窄焦点。她选择前方的一个目标。那可能是前面某人穿的粉色短裤，也可能是她能在远处看到的视觉信标，然后她缩小了注意力。再次像聚光灯只照在她选择的那个目标上，就好像她给周围的一切戴上了眼罩，她专注于那个目标，直到她到达并超过它，超过那个竞争对手或超过那个标记，然后她为自己设定下一个目标并集中
her attention there. So in a sense, she's taking over 26 miles and breaking it down into many small little competitions with herself, encouraging herself to find the next mark and double down until she gets there and passes by. So Luke A. Kins and Joan Benoit Samuelson are obviously elite athletes, but they're employing a psychological technique that the rest of us can also use. You call it narrow focus.
她的注意力在那里。所以从某种意义上说，她把26英里拆解成了许多与自己的小比赛，鼓励自己找到下一个标记并加倍努力，直到她到达并超过它。所以Luke Aikens和Joan Benoit Samuelson显然是精英运动员，但他们正在使用一种我们其他人也可以使用的心理技巧。你称之为狭窄焦点。
What is this technique and when is it most effective to use this technique? Yeah, so my research team and I were looking into these cases of these amazing athletes and seeing these similarities in what they are using to accomplish some amazing things. And we wondered if that's a tactic that could be translated and shared with people who aren't necessarily looking to break world records or defy the odds of gravity, but instead we're working towards pursuing just an everyday
这种技巧是什么？什么时候使用这种技巧最有效？是的，所以我的研究团队和我一直在研究这些了不起的运动员的案例，并看到了他们在实现一些惊人成就时所使用的相似之处。我们想知道，这是否是一种可以转化并分享给那些不一定想打破世界纪录或挑战重力的人的策略，而是那些正在努力追求日常
goal, maybe maintaining their own health. So we thought, I wonder if we can teach these people the strategy that elite athletes use. Can we design a set of instructions that people could hold on to in their own mind that would change the way that they look at the space around them? And could that encourage them and assist them in exercising more effectively, more efficiently, and more frequently? So we came up with a set of instructions
目标的人，也许是维持自己的健康。所以我们想，我想知道我们是否能教这些人精英运动员使用的策略。我们能否设计一套人们可以在脑海中记住的指令，从而改变他们看待周围空间的方式？这能否鼓励并帮助他们更有效、更高效、更频繁地锻炼？所以我们想出了一套指令，
that was asking them to choose a target, to find something in their environment. Maybe the stop sign up ahead, maybe the edge of a really colorful building that they can see a few blocks up, and to focus their attention there. To imagine that a spotlight is shining just on that, can see a few blocks up and to focus their attention there. To imagine that a spotlight is shining just on that and to sort of put on blinders or or just not pay attention to what's on the periphery.
要求他们选择一个目标，在环境中找到某样东西。也许是前方的停车标志，也许是他们能在几个街区外看到的色彩鲜艳的建筑的边缘，并将他们的注意力集中在那里。想象一束聚光灯只照在那上面，能看到几个街区外，并将他们的注意力集中在那里。想象一束聚光灯只照在那上面，并给周围的一切戴上眼罩，或者只是不关注外围的东西。
Now, what we found is that in fact they reported that it took 17% less physical exertion to walk the exact same distance when they were narrowly focusing their attention in contrast to looking at the world the way they normally do, which is in a more expanded way. So I think this is a study where you actually put ankle weights on people's legs, and again told some people to focus very hard on the finish line while other people were not told to focus very hard on the finish line. And the people who focused hard on the finish line didn't just exercise less effort to get
现在，我们发现，事实上他们报告说，当他们狭窄地集中注意力时，走同样的距离所消耗的体力减少了17%，这与他们通常看待世界的方式（即更广阔的方式）形成了对比。所以我认为这是一项研究，你实际上在人们的腿上绑了脚踝重量，并再次告诉一些人非常努力地专注于终点线，而另一些人则没有被告知要非常努力地专注于终点线。那些专注于终点线的人不仅付出的努力更少，
to the finish line. They actually felt the finish line was closer, which is remarkable. Exactly, that narrowed focus of attention produced a visual illusion of proximity. That goal looked closer to them than it did to people who were taking a more expanded view. And that illusion of proximity is actually what inspired them to walk faster. It seemed more feasible. The goal seemed looked to them quite literally closer at hand. And that was inspiring. That's what motivated them and encouraged them and gave them the energy to walk faster and led them to feel that it didn't hurt as much. So the fact that people who kept their eyes on the goal walked essentially 23% faster,
他们甚至觉得终点线更近了，这很了不起。没错，那种狭窄的注意力焦点产生了一种接近的视觉错觉。那个目标看起来比那些采取更广阔视野的人离他们更近。而这种接近的错觉正是激励他们走得更快的原因。它看起来更可行。目标在字面上看起来离他们更近。这很鼓舞人心。这激励了他们，鼓励了他们，给了他们走得更快的能量，并使他们觉得没那么痛苦。所以，那些盯着目标看的人走得比那些没看的人快了23%，
I think you found, than the people who didn't, tells us that this technique is really valuable in getting people to the finish line. Is that when narrow focus is most effective? It is. Yeah. So when we're looking for that extra boost to help us cross that finish line, either in the literal sense, like it was the case for our exercises, or maybe even in a metaphoric sense,
我想你发现了，这告诉我们这种技巧在帮助人们到达终点线方面确实很有价值。这就是狭窄焦点最有效的时候吗？是的。所以当我们寻找额外的推动力来帮助我们跨越终点线时，无论是字面意义上的，就像我们的锻炼者那样，还是隐喻意义上的，
there's a goal that we're working towards, and it seems near. But sometimes it can be a struggle for us to focus on our efforts. We might be pulled in other directions. A goal might sort of linger or fizzle out. That's when it's particularly effective. It's when it seems that it's close by, and yet we still need that extra push
有一个我们正在努力实现的目标，它看起来很近。但有时专注于我们的努力可能是一种挣扎。我们可能会被其他方向拉扯。一个目标可能会徘徊或逐渐消失。这就是它特别有效的时候。当它看起来很近，但我们仍然需要额外的推动力
to get us over the finish line. It's also really interesting, Emily. You've done some fascinating work, looking at how our inner drives and motivations can shape what it is that we see. I remember this really funny experiment you did, I believe with David Dunning many years ago, where you asked people to see the difference between the letter 13 and the capital letter
来帮助我们跨越终点线时。Emily，这也非常有趣。你做了一些引人入胜的工作，研究我们内在的驱动力和动机如何塑造我们所看到的东西。我记得你多年前和David Dunning做过一个非常有趣的实验，你要求人们在实验中区分数字13和字母
B in an experiment. Do you remember that study and what it showed? Sure. We took this simple line drawing, think of a capital letter B, and if you sort of pulled apart the pieces, the straight line on the left and the bubbles on the right, and gave it just a little bit of visual space between the two, there produces an ambiguity.
B。你还记得那个研究以及它展示了什么吗？当然。我们采用了这个简单的线条图，想象一个大写字母B，如果你把这些部分分开，左边的直线和右边的气泡，并在两者之间留出一点视觉空间，就会产生歧义。
Is it a B, or is it sort of a smushed together number 13? And what we did was we tried to incentivize one interpretation over the other. For half of the people, we said, the computer is going to randomly choose either a letter or a number to show to you. Just like at a slot machine, who knows what's going to come up, it could be a letter, it could be a number. But for you, if a letter comes up, then we'll ask you next to drink this delicious freshly squeezed orange juice that we just pressed a few minutes ago.
它是B，还是挤在一起的数字13？我们所做的是试图激励一种解释胜过另一种。对于一半的人，我们说，电脑将随机选择一个字母或数字展示给你。就像在老虎机上一样，谁知道会出现什么，可能是字母，也可能是数字。但对你来说，如果出现字母，那么我们接下来会请你喝这杯美味的、几分钟前刚榨好的新鲜橙汁。
But if a number pops up, we're gonna ask you to sample and tell us what you think about an organic veggie smoothie. Now, I made that organic veggie smoothie and it was noxious. I had put together canned okra, frozen peas, some pickled juice. It had a vivid green color and a noxious smell. And so I knew most people were interested in the orange juice, and as a result they were
但如果出现数字，我们将请你品尝并告诉我们你对有机蔬菜冰沙的看法。现在，我做了那个有机蔬菜冰沙，它很难喝。我把罐装秋葵、冷冻豌豆、一些腌菜汁放在一起。它有一种鲜艳的绿色和一种难闻的气味。所以我知道大多数人对橙汁感兴趣，因此他们
hoping that the computer was going to show them a letter. So then when we presented this ambiguous image, this B or 13, for just a half a second and ask them, okay, what did it show to you, and then we'll give you the drink that we'll have you taste next. What we found was that people overwhelmingly interpreted that figure as, in fact, a letter, their wish, their desire to get the orange juice by seeing a letter, by hoping that a letter appeared, actually led them to interpret that image in the more desirable way. You might think that the volunteers were not telling the truth, that they simply gave
希望电脑能给他们看一个字母。所以当我们展示这个模糊的图像，这个B或13，只持续了半秒钟，并问他们，好吧，它向你展示了什么，然后我们会给你接下来要品尝的饮料。我们发现，人们绝大多数将那个图形解释为字母，他们的愿望，他们通过看到字母来获得橙汁的渴望，通过希望出现字母，实际上导致他们以更理想的方式解释了那个图像。你可能认为志愿者没有说实话，他们只是给出了
the answer that would allow them to avoid the foul smelling drink. But the study also included techniques to test whether participants were lying. It also flipped the conditions for half the volunteers. Orange juice was now associated with the letter and the smoothie was associated with the number. We found now that the majority of people saw it as a 13 rather than a B when the numbers were what was tagged to the orange juice. So I find it interesting that so much of your work has looked at how our motivations and desires shape what we see, and this book is really asking
那个能让他们避免喝下难闻饮料的答案。但这项研究也包括了测试参与者是否撒谎的技巧。它还为一半的志愿者颠倒了条件。橙汁现在与字母相关联，冰沙与数字相关联。我们现在发现，当数字与橙汁挂钩时，大多数人将其视为13而不是B。所以我发现有趣的是，你的很多工作都研究了我们的动机和欲望如何塑造我们所看到的东西，而这本书实际上是在问
if the arrow can run in the opposite direction, can what we see and visualize shape our motivations. I think that's exactly right. I think that's sort of the hidden secret about goal pursuit, is that what we see is really tied to what we think, what we decide, and what we do. And if we feel like we're struggling in that regard, we're not making the decisions, or we're not seeing the outcomes that we're hoping for, maybe part of the problem, and maybe part of the solution, could be how we're looking at the world
箭头是否可以向相反方向运行，我们所看到和想象的东西能否塑造我们的动机。我认为这完全正确。我认为这就是关于目标追求的隐藏秘密，即我们所看到的与我们的想法、决定和行为息息相关。如果我们觉得在这方面挣扎，我们没有做出决定，或者我们没有看到我们所希望的结果，也许问题的一部分，也许解决方案的一部分，可能在于我们如何看待周围的世界
around us. We've seen how keeping our eyes on the finish line can help us get there faster. But what happens when we don't know where the finish line is, when we can't see the target? What happens when we don't know where we're going? That's coming up next. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In many cases it makes sense to say, keep your eyes on the finish line. Narrowing your attention in this way can help you reach your goal, especially if that goal is clear.
。我们已经看到了盯着终点线如何帮助我们更快地到达那里。但当我们不知道终点线在哪里，当我们看不到目标时会发生什么？当我们不知道我们要去哪里时会发生什么？接下来我们将探讨这个问题。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是Shankar Vedanta。在许多情况下，说“盯着终点线”是有道理的。以这种方式缩小你的注意力可以帮助你实现目标，特别是如果那个目标很明确的话。
If you jump out of a plane without a parachute, you know that your target is a net. Get to your target and you live. Take your eyes off it. You die. But what happens when you don't know what your target is, or it's so far off that you can't see it? What do you do if the challenge and the solution are too abstract to wrap your mind around? A case where all these things are true is saving for retirement.
如果你在没有降落伞的情况下跳出飞机，你知道你的目标是一个网。到达你的目标，你就活下来了。把目光移开。你就死了。但当你不知道你的目标是什么，或者它太远以至于你看不见它时会发生什么？如果你面临的挑战和解决方案太抽象，以至于你无法理解，该怎么办？所有这些情况都成立的一个案例是为退休储蓄。
If you're in your 60s, it's easy to be hyper focused on retirement because the finish line is right in front of you. But it's not realistic to ask people in their 20s to be narrowly focused on retirement, even though it's really important to save when you're young. Emily saw this issue in action when she asked college students whether they were saving for retirement. Well, what I found was that 55 out of 60 of my students who were on the brink of graduating, setting up their first job, thinking about entering the quote unquote, real world, 55 of those 60s said they had no thoughts about retirement. They weren't planning for it, they weren't currently saving for it, despite the fact that they all did have jobs right now. This just wasn't on their radar.
如果你在60多岁，很容易对退休过度关注，因为终点线就在你面前。但要求20多岁的人对退休保持狭窄的关注是不现实的，尽管年轻时储蓄真的很重要。Emily在询问大学生是否在为退休储蓄时看到了这个问题。嗯，我发现，在我60名即将毕业、准备第一份工作、考虑进入所谓的“现实世界”的学生中，有55人说他们没有考虑过退休。他们没有为此做计划，目前也没有为此储蓄，尽管他们现在都有工作。这根本不在他们的考虑范围内。
And when I asked them, well, why? The most frequently offered answer was, because that just seems so far away, retirement seems too far off for it to be relevant today. And of course, every financial advisor will tell you the single most important thing you can do if you're saving for retirement is not necessarily to save a lot of money, but to start early. And starting early makes a huge difference in terms of what you end up with, what your
当我问他们，为什么？最常给出的答案是，因为那看起来太遥远了，退休看起来太遥远，以至于今天与他们无关。当然，每一位财务顾问都会告诉你，如果你在为退休储蓄，你能做的最重要的事情不一定是存很多钱，而是尽早开始。尽早开始在最终结果方面会产生巨大的差异，
nest egg looks like when you retire 30, 40 years down the road. So if we have the psychological problem that it's really hard to think about something that's 40 years away as being a finish line that we can see. You came up with a really interesting technique to try and fix this problem. What did you do Emily? Well, I used this demonstration that I created, but it was really based off of how Hirschfeld's research, a fellow social psychologist, who provided the solid scientific evidence that this may be effective, and I created a demonstration for my students. So I took a photograph of their face. I took a snapshot and I used a photo-morphing software
当你30、40年后退休时，你的养老金看起来会是什么样。所以如果我们有这样一个心理问题，即很难把40年后发生的事情当作我们可以看到的终点线。你提出了一个非常有趣的技巧来尝试解决这个问题。你做了什么，Emily？嗯，我使用了我创造的这个演示，但它确实是基于另一位社会心理学家How Hirschfeld的研究，他提供了这可能有效的坚实科学证据，我为我的学生创建了一个演示。所以我拍了一张他们脸的照片。我拍了一张快照，并使用了照片变形软件
to create a more aged version of themselves. So for some of my female students, I aged their face with that of Maya Angelou. They saw a little bit more white hair. They saw a little bit more wrinkles on their face for some of the men. I morphed them with Dan Rather and other high profile older, older figures so that they too could have that experience. And I printed off those pictures for themselves so that they could literally see what they might look like in retirement.
来创建他们更年老的版本。所以对于我的一些女学生，我用Maya Angelou的脸来老化她们的脸。她们看到了更多的白发。她们在脸上看到了更多的皱纹，对于一些男人来说。我把他们与Dan Rather和其他高调的年长人物进行了变形，这样他们也能有那种体验。我为他们打印了那些照片，这样他们就能真正看到他们在退休时可能的样子。
They took a few minutes to jot down their thoughts about that, what would you be doing in retirement, how would you spend your time, who would you be with, what hobbies would you have? And what I was trying to do was create an illusion of proximity, but in this case, temporal proximity, taking that far off distant, retired future self and making it relevant and present in the here and now. They were literally seeing themselves as a retired person and imagining what that life would be like today. And then I asked them, what do you think about retirement? Do you think you'll start saving for retirement today
他们花了几分钟写下他们对那件事的想法，退休后你会做什么，你会如何度过你的时间，你会和谁在一起，你会有什么爱好？我试图做的是创造一种接近的错觉，但在这种情况下是时间上的接近，把那个遥远的、退休后的未来自我带入当下，使其变得相关和存在。他们实际上是在看着自己作为一个退休的人，并想象今天那种生活会是什么样子。然后我问他们，你对退休有什么看法？你认为你会从今天开始为退休储蓄吗
this week with your next paycheck? And the vast majority of them now after having gone through that experience said, yes. There's another visualization technique that Emily says can be useful, even though it's counterintuitive. She says it can be helpful to imagine the obstacles that may get in our way
这周用你的下一份工资？绝大多数人在经历了那种体验后说，是的。Emily说还有另一种可视化技巧可能很有用，尽管它违反直觉。她说，想象在我们朝着目标努力时可能阻碍我们的障碍是有帮助的。
as we're working toward a goal. Now, that might not seem like it would work if I'm trying to motivate myself. I'm trying to get off the starting blocks for this new goal that I've set. Why would I wanna think about the likely path of destruction that I might experience? Why do I want to focus on the things that are going to pose me complications? And that might stymie my progress. But really, it is important because thinking about those obstacles
现在，如果我试图激励自己，这看起来可能行不通。我正试图为我设定的这个新目标离开起跑线。为什么我想考虑我可能经历的破坏性路径？为什么我想关注那些会给我带来复杂情况的事情？这可能会阻碍我的进步。但实际上，这很重要，因为提前考虑那些障碍
in advance also gives us the opportunity to foreshadow what might be the solutions should we experience those obstacles. The metaphor I like to use is thinking about a sinking ship. If you're on a ship and it starts sinking, that's not the time you want to start looking for the life preservers. You already want to know where they are so that you can quickly go get one. And the same is true when we're thinking about goal pursuit and setting goals in an effective way. We want to prepare for what the obstacles might be, have that backup plan, that emergency escape route ready, so that when we're in the thick of it and a problem arises, we don't
也让我们有机会预见如果我们遇到这些障碍，解决方案可能是什么。我喜欢用的隐喻是考虑一艘正在下沉的船。如果你在船上，它开始下沉，那不是你想要开始寻找救生衣的时候。你已经想知道它们在哪里，这样你就可以迅速去拿一个。当我们考虑目标追求并以有效的方式设定目标时，情况也是如此。我们想要为可能出现的障碍做好准备，准备好那个备份计划，那个紧急逃生路线，这样当我们身处其中且问题出现时，我们就不
have to then try to find the time and the resources to figure out how we'll move through that obstacle. We already want to know how to do it. Emily describes a moment when this sort of preparation paid off a swimmer Michael Phelps. It was at the Olympics in 2008. Michael Phelps is an incredible athlete as we all know. He was the most decorated Olympic athlete of all time. In 2008, he was poised to break a world record.
必再试图寻找时间和资源来弄清楚我们将如何克服那个障碍。我们已经想知道该怎么做了。Emily描述了这种准备工作如何让游泳运动员Michael Phelps受益的时刻。那是在2008年的奥运会上。Michael Phelps是一位了不起的运动员，我们都知道。他是史上获得奖牌最多的奥运选手。2008年，他准备打破世界纪录。
You have a chance to witness rare history live here in Beijing. In that single Olympiad, he was on the brink of winning more gold medals than any other Olympic athlete had ever done before. He had just the 200 fly in front of him for this record to be beat. But when he jumped off the starting blocks, his goggles started to leak. Soon, they were entirely filled with water. Now, for most people, that might mean disaster, but for him it didn't, because this was something that he had planned for. He had foreshadowed this obstacle, and he already had his plan of attack if this should happen.
你有机会在这里亲眼见证罕见的历史。在那届奥运会上，他即将赢得比以往任何其他奥运选手都多的金牌。他面前只有200米蝶泳，这个纪录就能被打破。但当他跳下起跑台时，他的护目镜开始漏水。很快，它们完全充满了水。现在，对大多数人来说，这可能意味着灾难，但对他来说并没有，因为这是他已经计划好的事情。他预见到了这个障碍，并且如果这种情况发生，他已经有了他的攻击计划。
He went to counting his strokes. He knew exactly how many strokes it would take for him to get from one length of the pool to the other. And so, even though he was now swimming blind, he just went to his backup plan. He countered his strokes. He won that race. Is it gonna be a world record? Yes!
他开始数他的划水次数。他确切地知道他需要多少次划水才能从泳池的一端游到另一端。所以，即使他现在是盲游，他也只是执行了他的备份计划。他数着他的划水次数。他赢得了那场比赛。这会是世界纪录吗？是的！
And he went on to win another 13 gold medal. The greatest Olympic champion of all time. Tosses the goggles on the deck. The techniques that Emily used to help her students imagine retirement and that Michael Phelps used to visualize the length of the pool in front of him, involve something that Emily calls materializing. used to visualize the length of the pool in front of him, involves something that Emily calls materializing. The idea, she says, is to take something that is abstract, amorphous, and hidden, and make it tangible, immediate, and mentally visible.
他后来又赢得了另一枚金牌。史上最伟大的奥运冠军。把护目镜扔在甲板上。Emily用来帮助她的学生想象退休的技巧，以及Michael Phelps用来可视化他面前泳池长度的技巧，涉及Emily称之为“具体化”的东西。
The idea of materializing is just that, that we can create a concrete visual image for ourselves, and that might help us accomplish our goals in ways that just leaving it in our mind might not. I think a great example of this that resonates with my everyday life is that if we think of our to-do list, those elements, those items that we just leave in our mind, those little nagging concerns,
具体化的想法就是这样，我们可以为自己创造一个具体的视觉形象，这可能有助于我们以仅仅留在脑海中可能无法实现的方式实现我们的目标。我认为这在我的日常生活中产生共鸣的一个很好的例子是，如果我们想到我们的待办事项清单，那些元素，那些我们只是留在脑海中的项目，那些小小的烦恼，
never quite make it to the top of the list. When you have a moment of free time to get something done off your personal to-do list, you forget about it, right? You forget what will pop up in your mind in the middle of the night. But we almost always make good on the things that we put into our calendar. So those items that we've set for 9.45 this morning, it's far more likely that we'll make it to those that will meet those obligations and we'll get that done than the things that we just hope that we'll make it to those, that we'll meet those obligations and we'll get that done, then the things that we just hope that we'll remember.
从来没有真正排到清单的最前面。当你有一点空闲时间从你的个人待办事项清单上完成某事时，你忘记了它，对吧？你忘记了半夜会出现在你脑海中的东西。但我们几乎总是会完成我们放入日历中的事情。所以那些我们为今天早上9点45分设定的项目，我们更有可能完成那些义务，我们会完成它，而不是那些我们只是希望我们会完成那些，我们会履行那些义务，我们会完成它，而不是那些我们只是希望我们会记住的事情。
So there's great power in what it is that we see, which is why a piece of advice that I offer is to schedule into our calendar, those things that we might not think warrant scheduling, it might just be a reminder to make an important phone call to schedule an appointment. Well, we can schedule an appointment with ourselves to schedule that appointment with somebody else. We prioritize those things that are in our calendar that we can literally see as part of our daily obligations over those things that we just leave in our own mind.
所以我们所看到的东西有巨大的力量，这就是为什么我提供的一个建议是，把那些我们可能认为不值得安排的事情安排到我们的日历中，它可能只是一个提醒，打一个重要的电话来预约。好吧，我们可以和自己预约来安排与别人的预约。我们优先考虑那些在我们的日历中，我们可以真正将其视为日常义务一部分的事情，而不是那些我们只是留在自己脑海中的事情。
And that's the power of materializing. We've talked about two techniques to manipulate what we see in order to shape what we do. We've talked about narrow focus, keeping your eye on a target to help you get there. And we've talked about how materializing, hard to see things can make them easier to achieve. The third idea you explore has to do with framing, the context in which we see things. Tell me about a study conducted by Anne Thorndike at Massachusetts General Hospital. Thorndijk and a research team were working at the cafeteria of Massachusetts General Hospital. They had as a corporate goal to improve the health of their employees that were eating in the cafeteria
这就是具体化的力量。我们已经讨论了三种操纵我们所看到的东西以塑造我们所做的事情的技巧。我们讨论了狭窄焦点，盯着目标看以帮助你到达那里。我们讨论了具体化，难以看到的东西可以使它们更容易实现。你探索的第三个想法与框架有关，即我们看待事物的背景。告诉我Anne Thorndike在麻省总医院进行的一项研究。Thorndijk和研究团队在麻省总医院的自助餐厅工作。他们的企业目标是改善在自助餐厅吃饭的员工的健康，
by trying to nudge or inspire or visually cue healthier choices at lunchtime or when people are getting snacks or at breakfast. And what they did was use two aspects of visual framing to try to encourage these healthier choices. First of all, they put these color-coded labels on the food. They put stickers on them. They put green stickers on the healthiest of options, the fruits and vegetables, the nutrient-dense foods that they were hoping that their employees would choose. They put red stickers on those that had high calories and low nutritional value, like candy bars, and they put yellow stickers on those that people should approach with caution.
通过尝试在午餐时间或人们吃零食或早餐时推动或激励或视觉提示更健康的选择。他们所做的是使用视觉框架的两个方面来尝试鼓励这些更健康的选择。首先，他们给食物贴上了颜色编码的标签。他们给它们贴上了贴纸。他们给最健康的选择，即水果和蔬菜，他们希望员工选择的营养丰富的食物贴上了绿色贴纸。他们给那些高热量、低营养价值的东西，比如糖果棒，贴上了红色贴纸，给那些人们应该谨慎对待的东西贴上了黄色贴纸。
So they use these color-coded labels to just encourage a conscientiousness or draw people's attention to the foods that they should be eating and those foods that they shouldn't be eating. Now, they coupled that also with visual placement. They put those green-stickered items at eye level on the shelves. They put the red and the yellow items on the shelves that were higher up or lower down and less likely to just literally fall into people's visual frame. And what they found was that that was quite effective.
所以他们使用这些颜色编码的标签来鼓励一种自觉性，或者吸引人们注意他们应该吃的食物和他们不应该吃的食物。现在，他们还将此与视觉放置结合起来。他们把那些贴有绿色贴纸的物品放在货架上视线水平的位置。他们把红色和黄色的物品放在更高或更低、不太可能直接落入人们视觉框架的货架上。他们发现这非常有效。
They were looking at what were the net sales of these red and green and yellow colored items and they found that over the course of the study that people actually made significantly healthier choices in the long run. So if I remember the numbers correctly, two years after the study began, the number of green tagged items bought rose by 12% and the number of sweetened beverages basically sodas dropped by 39%. Exactly. And those items that had red tags on them dropped by 20% as well. So people were more likely to eat the green tagged items to choose the green tagged So people were more likely to eat the green tag to items, to choose the green tag to items,
他们正在观察这些红色、绿色和黄色物品的净销售额，他们发现，在研究过程中，人们在长期内实际上做出了明显更健康的选择。所以如果我没记错数字的话，研究开始两年后，购买的绿色标签物品数量上升了12%，含糖饮料（基本上是苏打水）的数量下降了39%。没错。那些贴有红色标签的物品也下降了20%。所以人们更有可能吃绿色标签的物品，选择绿色标签的物品，
and we're less likely to choose unhealthy foods and sugar, sweetened beverages. So I understand Emily that you have a three-year-old son, and you have used some of these visual framing strategies at home to shape what he eats and to also shape what he doesn't eat. What are you trying to keep him from getting to and how do you do it?
并且不太可能选择不健康的食物和含糖饮料。所以我明白Emily，你有一个三岁的儿子，你在家里使用了一些这些视觉框架策略来塑造他吃的东西，也塑造他不吃的东西。你试图阻止他接触什么，你是怎么做的？
So his kryptonite, what really does him in, are those little pouches of basically baby smoothies, things that you would give to a six month old to help teach them how to eat non-milk foods, right? It's the good, it's introduction to food level one. But he loves those things, and that's his go-to treat. Now, for a six-month-old, they're great, but for a three-and-a-half-year-old, they're, they're not going to fill up his stomach, and for him, they're the equivalent of empty calories.
所以他的氪星石，真正让他受不了的是那些基本上是婴儿冰沙的小袋子，你会给六个月大的孩子吃的东西，以帮助教他们如何吃非奶类食物，对吧？这是好的，这是食物一级介绍。但他喜欢那些东西，那是他的首选零食。现在，对于六个月大的孩子来说，它们很棒，但对于三岁半的孩子来说，它们不会填饱他的肚子，对他来说，它们相当于空热量。
So what we have done is put them first on a high-up shelf, literally out of his reach, out of his line of sight, and that worked for about a week. Then he found his stairs from the bathroom. He would pull the stairs that he usually uses to wash his hands. He pulled them into the pantry. So now the stairs live in the pantry, and he can reach those little pouches. We found him one early morning having quite a feast off of those little pouches. So then we had to up our game. And what we did next was put them on that same high-up shelf, but now out of sight. We hid them behind the cast-iron skillets on the shelf. So he couldn't quite see them. And when you stack two cast-iron skillets, it's actually too heavy for a three and a half
所以我们所做的是把它们先放在高处的架子上，字面上在他的够不着的地方，在他的视线之外，这奏效了大约一个星期。然后他从浴室找到了他的楼梯。他会拉他通常用来洗手的楼梯。他把它们拉进了储藏室。所以现在楼梯住在储藏室里，他可以够到那些小袋子。我们在一个清晨发现他正在那些小袋子上大快朵颐。所以我们不得不升级我们的游戏。我们接下来做的是把它们放在同一个高处的架子上，但现在看不见了。我们把它们藏在架子上的铸铁煎锅后面。所以他看不见它们。当你堆叠两个铸铁煎锅时，实际上对一个三岁半的孩子来说太重了，无法推开。所以现在，他和我都必须成为有意识的决策者，关于他什么时候得到一个袋子，因为他需要我的帮助才能得到它们。
year old to push out of the way. So now, both he and I have to be conscientious decision-makers about when he gets a pouch because he needs my help in order to get them. scientist decision-maker is about when he gets a pouch because he needs my help in order to get them. You also find there are things too that you can do that help him do more of something rather than less of something and one of them has to do with books and reading. What do you do Emily? So it is bedroom. We have a gigantic bureau.
关于他什么时候得到一个袋子，因为他需要我的帮助才能得到它们。你还发现有些事情你可以做，帮助他做更多的事情而不是更少的事情，其中之一与书籍和阅读有关。你做什么，Emily？所以这是卧室。我们有一个巨大的衣柜。
It's from the 1960s or something and you know it could have housed one of the first old fashion televisions that are three feet deep and weigh a hundred and fifty pounds. It could hold something like that or it could have held somebody's wool sweaters. What we've done is instead fill it entirely with his books. Every single shelf is filled with books. There's boxes of books at all of the levels. It's about seven feet tall and it's entirely filled with his books. There's doors on this, on the top and on the bottom. And we keep his doors open.
它是1960年代的还是什么的，你知道它本可以容纳第一批老式电视机之一，那种三英尺深、重150磅的电视机。它本可以容纳那样的东西，或者它本可以容纳某人的羊毛衫。我们所做的是把它完全装满他的书。每一个架子都装满了书。所有层级都有书箱。它大约七英尺高，完全装满了他的书。这上面有门，上面和下面都有。我们保持门开着。
Now, in the middle of the night when he calls for help and we need to go in there, we've bonked our heads on those open doors more times than we care to admit. And we have the bruises on our forehead to show for it, but we still keep the doors open, because we want that to be what, when he wakes up in the morning
现在，在半夜他呼救时，我们需要进去，我们撞到那些开着的门上的次数比我们愿意承认的要多。我们的额头上还有淤青可以证明这一点，但我们仍然保持门开着，因为我们希望那是，当他早上醒来时
and when he goes to sleep, that's what he sees are all of his books. We've looked at three techniques involving the visual system in the brain that can help you motivate yourself and others. You can narrow your focus, you can make something tangible what Emily calls materializing, and you can arrange the context of what you see to encourage certain behaviors. Emily calls this visual framing. When we come back, we explore another idea that can help you when you feel like giving up. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Emily Balcharis is a psychologist and the author of Clearer Closer Better, how successful people see the world. Emily looks at how the
当他去睡觉时，他看到的就是他所有的书。我们研究了三种涉及大脑视觉系统的技巧，可以帮助你激励自己和他人。你可以缩小你的焦点，你可以让某样东西变得具体，Emily称之为“具体化”，你可以安排你所看到的东西的背景来鼓励某些行为。Emily称之为“视觉框架”。当我们回来时，我们将探索另一个想法，当你想要放弃时可以帮助你。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是Shankar Vedantam。Emily Balcharis是一位心理学家，也是《更清晰、更近、更好：成功人士如何看待世界》一书的作者。Emily研究了如何
visual system in the mind is closely connected with our drives and motivations. What we choose to see and what we choose not to see can shape what we do. We began this conversation by looking at how we can narrow our site to achieve specific goals. Emily says there are also times when we can use our vision to help us do the opposite, to zoom out and see a more complete picture. Emily, some years ago, you asked a small group of women
大脑中的视觉系统与我们的驱动力和动机紧密相连。我们选择看什么，选择不看什么，可以塑造我们的行为。我们通过探讨如何缩小视野以实现特定目标开启了这次对话。艾米丽说，有时我们也可以利用视觉来帮助我们做相反的事情，即拉远视角，看到更完整的图景。艾米丽，几年前，你曾邀请一小群女性
to take a survey about their lives. You asked them to list their dreams and hopes. What did they tell you? They did this survey in the privacy of their own home. Nobody else was around. They were asked to set aside an hour or so to take a step back and think about all aspects of their life and what would be the ideal in each of those facets of life.
参与一项关于她们生活的调查。你让她们列出自己的梦想和希望。她们告诉了你什么？她们是在自己家中私下完成这项调查的，周围没有其他人。她们被要求留出一个小时左右的时间，退后一步，思考生活的各个方面，以及在这些生活层面中，什么是理想的状态。
They thought about what would their perfect career look like, how many hours would they be working, what sort of education would they have received in order to prepare for that career, what did their personal life look like, what kinds of relationships did they have, did they have children, did they live with anybody, what home are they living in? Now, all of these are important decisions, and of course, all of these are things that we do think about, but rarely do we give ourselves the opportunity to think about them at the same time and to decide what's a priority and what isn't. But that's what this survey was encouraging people to do. On their own, in the privacy of their own home, they were defining what their ideal life looked like.
她们思考了完美的职业是什么样的，每周工作多少小时，为了准备这份职业需要接受什么样的教育，个人生活是什么样的，拥有什么样的关系，是否有孩子，是否与人同住，住在什么样的房子里？现在，所有这些都是重要的决定，当然，这些都是我们确实会考虑的事情，但我们很少给自己机会同时思考这些问题，并决定什么是优先事项，什么不是。但这正是这项调查鼓励人们去做的事情。在她们自己的家中，在私密的环境里，她们正在定义自己理想的生活是什么样的。
So some weeks later, you invited the women to a pop-up shop, and you asked them to bring a mentor with them. Another woman, this could have been a mom, a friend, a cousin, but this was actually not just a shop. This was actually a social experiment. What were the things on sale at the pop-up shop? Well, on the shelves at the store, there were canisters. There was an array of canisters in one
几周后，你邀请这些女性来到一家快闪店，并要求她们带上一位导师。这可以是母亲、朋友或表亲，但这实际上不仅仅是一家商店，而是一个社会实验。快闪店里卖的是什么？在商店的货架上，摆放着罐子。在一个区域里有一排罐子，
section, and it offered options. With the question posed above on this placard that said, how many hours would you work a week? There were cans that had a response of five hours, or 10 to 15, 15 to 20, 30 to 40, 40 plus. We gave them a basket when they walked into this shop, and they could walk around, look at all of the shelves, entertain all of the questions, and pick off the canister that reflected how many hours they wanted to work. They would go to the next aisle, they would walk to the next segment of the shop, and they would see another question, who do you want to live with? And there would be bags that had different answers on there, like living alone, live
它提供了多种选择。上面的标语提出了一个问题：你每周工作多少小时？有些罐子里的回答是5小时，或者10到15小时，15到20小时，30到40小时，40小时以上。当她们走进这家店时，我们给了她们一个篮子，她们可以四处走动，查看所有的货架，思考所有的问题，并挑选出反映她们想工作多少小时的罐子。她们会走到下一个过道，走到商店的下一个区域，看到另一个问题：你想和谁住在一起？那里会有写着不同答案的袋子，比如独自居住，
with a roommate, live with a significant other, be married, and they would choose the bag that reflected their answer to that choice as well. So what they perhaps picked up on, but maybe didn't realize in the moment, was that the basket that we gave them was of a specific shape and size, and that they wouldn't be able to necessarily max out and choose the most desirable aspect of life across all of these different facets and have them all still fit in the basket. So in a sense, the social experiment was encouraging them to think about the trade-offs that might have to be made in order for them to achieve what their perfect life would look like. And as they're walking around this store, of course, they were walking around with their best friend, their law school buddies, their mother, cousin, and they were having conversations. Everybody was playing this game.
与室友同住，与伴侣同住，结婚，她们也会选择反映她们对该选择的答案的袋子。所以她们可能注意到了，但当时可能没有意识到的是，我们给她们的篮子形状和大小是特定的，她们不一定能把所有这些不同生活层面的最理想选择都装进篮子里。因此，从某种意义上说，这个社会实验是在鼓励她们思考为了实现理想生活可能需要做出的权衡。当她们在店里走动时，当然，她们是和最好的朋友、法学院同学、母亲、表亲一起走动的，她们在进行交谈。每个人都在玩这个游戏。
Everybody was trying to shop for their perfect life, but they realized the challenges of it. It brought up interesting points. Like, for example, there was one woman there with her mother, and when her mother pulled off the shelf, living alone, even though she was still married to our protagonist's father, well, that inspired not only a laugh,
每个人都在试图为自己的完美生活“购物”，但她们意识到了其中的挑战。这引出了一些有趣的观点。例如，有一位女士和她的母亲在一起，当她的母亲从货架上拿走“独自居住”时，尽管她仍然与我们主角的父亲结婚，这不仅引发了一阵笑声，
but a pretty deep conversation about, well, why would not only a laugh, but a pretty deep conversation about, well, why would you choose that? You're still married to dad. So the conversations were really interesting to listen to. And we're pretty deep ones where these women were having intense conversations about, well, what would an ideal life look like for me? What would it look like for you? And they were helping each other to figure that out.
还引发了一场相当深入的对话：为什么会选择那个？你还和爸爸结婚呢。所以这些对话听起来非常有趣。而且是非常深入的对话，这些女性在激烈地讨论：对我来说，理想的生活是什么样的？对你来说又是什么样的？她们在互相帮助弄清楚这一点。
So these women collect the various things that they've essentially bought at the store and they come to the checkout counter and waiting for them there is you. What do you do? Well they didn't realize it, but I had saved their answers from that survey that they had taken at home in private. Down in the basement of this shop was a whole data analytics team that was piping up to the iPad, the check out register that I had access to was telling me their responses. They were reminding me of what people had identified as the ideal way to live this aspect of their life. And I could contrast that to what they had put in their basket in this moment. So, we had a conversation.
所以这些女性收集了她们在店里“买”到的各种东西，来到结账柜台，而你在那里等着她们。你做了什么？她们没有意识到，但我保存了她们在家里私下完成的那份调查的答案。在这家店的地下室里，有一个完整的数据分析团队，他们将数据传输到我能访问的iPad结账收银机上，告诉我她们的回答。他们提醒我人们之前认定的理想生活方式是什么。我可以将其与她们此刻放入篮子里的东西进行对比。于是，我们进行了交谈。
I sort of surprised them with the fact that I knew what they had said when they were alone at home and brought to their attention where it differed after they had a conversation with their mom or their best friend and asked them to explain why those differences existed in those areas that we had found them to be. And what they actually found, these conversations were really amazing, was that this experience of having these conversations with these important sources of social support
我用我知道她们在家独自一人时所说的话给她们带来了一些惊喜，并让她们注意到在与母亲或最好的朋友交谈后，她们的选择与之前有何不同，并要求她们解释为什么在这些领域存在差异。她们实际上发现——这些对话真的很棒——这种与重要的社会支持来源进行对话的经历，
actually led the women to make more ambitious choices. The majority of women made more ambitious choices. They decided they wanted to spend more time at work, or they wanted to go back to school to further their education. But they made those more ambitious choices in the areas that they had on their own, identified as being the most important and meaningful facets of their life. So, what this suggested to me was that rather than this idea that women in particular
实际上引导女性做出了更雄心勃勃的选择。大多数女性做出了更雄心勃勃的选择。她们决定想花更多时间在工作上，或者想重返校园深造。但她们在自己认定为生活中最重要和最有意义的领域做出了这些更雄心勃勃的选择。所以，这向我表明，与其说女性在互相推动对方去“拥有一切”、去成为万能的人、去在生活的每个方面都做到最好，不如说这些对话并不是在做这些事。相反，这些女性在支持彼此的个人抱负，并鼓励人们投资于对自己最重要的事情。这甚至可能与她们之前认为重要的东西形成对比。例如，有三位一起在法学院学习的女性，
are pushing each other to have it all, to be everything, to be the best at every aspect of life, that wasn't what these conversations were doing. Instead, these women were supporting each other's own personal ambitions and encouraging people to invest in what was most important to them. And that might be even in contrast to what was important to them. For instance, there are three women who had studied in law school together,
她们都在纽约市非常有竞争力的公司工作，其中一个人想远离那种生活，那种她们共同努力实现的生活。而这两位仍然身处那个世界、仍然努力跻身于这种高强度职业顶峰的法学院好友，对她们的朋友想要离开公司、搬到一个完全不同的城市、改变法律方向去从事压力较小且更具支持性的工作，给予了极大的支持。
and were all at very competitive firms in New York City, and one of them wanted to pull away from that life, the life that they had all been working collectively to achieve. And these two law school buddies who were still in that world and were still striving to be at the top of this intense career, we're incredibly supportive of their friends want to leave the firm, to move to an entirely different city, and to change a focus and law to something that was less demanding and more supportive.
所以，当有人让你在自己家里做一份调查，说，你知道，思考一下这些不同的事情。然后你得出了结论。你可能花了半小时、45分钟。你列出了一份答案清单。这感觉与来到商店，看到选择在眼前视觉化，看到通过放入篮子里的东西所做出的权衡，
So when someone asks you to take a survey in your own home and says, you know, think about these different things. And you come up with it. You spend maybe half an hour, 45 minutes with it. You come up with a list of answers. That feels entirely different than coming to the store, seeing the choices made visual in front of you, seeing visually the trade-offs that you're making by putting what you're
与你生命中重要的人进行对话，这在心理上与仅仅问人们什么对你重要是完全不同的。这里发生了什么，艾米丽？我认为那种购物体验引发了一种“宽框架”思考。我们很少有机会思考我们生活拼图的所有不同部分是如何组合在一起的。通常，我们只是在处理今天的紧急事务，或者在做关于职业的选择，但同时思考这对我的
putting into the basket, having the conversations with this other person who's important in your life, there's something that's happening here that's psychologically very different than just asking people what's important to you, what's happening here Emily? I think what that shopping experience did was induce a wide bracket. We rarely take the opportunity to think about how all the different pieces of our life's puzzle come together. Oftentimes, we're just putting out today's fire or we're making a choice about our career, but it's challenging to also think about simultaneously the ramifications for what that means for my
个人幸福、家庭生活或对他人的义务意味着什么，是很有挑战性的。我们往往目光短浅，只关注脑海中最突出或最显眼的事情。但购物体验的作用是把人们拉回来。它有助于看到森林，而不仅仅是眼前的树木，并意识到在这个空间里的一个选择可能意味着在另一个空间里的权衡。这就是购物体验的作用，它确实把生活的各个方面都摆在了她们眼前，
personal well-being or for my family life or my obligations to others. We tend to be more myopically focused or focusing just on whatever is most salient or visible in our mind's eye. But what the shopping experience did was sort of pull people back. It helps to see the forest, not just the tree in front of us, and to realize that a choice in this space might mean this trade-off in another. That's what the shopping experience did, was literally put all facets of life before their eyes,
而这些支持性的对话把那些选择和并置真正摆在了她们面前，引发了一种宽广的生活视角，使选择与人们试图实现的这种整体观产生共鸣，而不是仅仅关注当下。所以，你用的那些词让我印象深刻，因为这就像爬到山顶，当你爬到顶峰时，
and these supportive conversations that were being had were putting those choices and those juxtapositions literally on the table in front of them, inducing this sort of wide expansive take on life and making the choices resonate more with this holistic view that people were trying to achieve rather than just focusing on the here and now. So, I'm struck by the words you use there because it's almost like climbing to the top of a mountain and when you climb to the top and get to the top from the peak, it's not
不仅风景看起来更好，而且地形看起来也不同了。你确实因为海拔高而看得更清楚。没错。是的，我们有了非常不同的视角。我的意思是，当我们站在山顶时，我们可以看到森林地面上的多条路径，而不是像我们在森林地面上时，任何一条路径呈现给我们的仅仅是向左或向右的转弯。你有没有使用过这些技巧来帮助你度过新冠疫情？
just the view looks better, but that the terrain looks different. You actually see better with altitude. Exactly. Yeah, we have a very different perspective. I mean, we can see the multitude of paths on the forest floor when we're at the top of the mountain, rather than just the left or the right turn that any one path is presented to us when we're on that forest floor. Have you used any of these techniques to help you to help get you through the COVID pandemic?
哦，当然。为了度过新冠疫情，对我来说，“宽框架”非常重要。所以我一直保留着电子日历，把它放在手机上，它与我的电脑同步。但我意识到，这并没有给我提供我需要的反馈，让我知道我一天中是否完成了任何事情。新冠疫情期间，人们试图同时管理的事情太多了，我很难找到一个时刻来反思我今天完成了什么，以及这与我实际的待办事项清单相比如何。仅仅在日历上看到它并知道
Oh, definitely. To get through the COVID pandemic, for me, the wide bracket has been really important. So I always have kept an electronic calendar, keep it on my phone, it syncs with my computers. But what I realized was that that wasn't giving me like the feedback that I needed to know whether I was getting anything done in the day. The COVID, I mean, there's so much that people are trying to simultaneously manage that it was really hard for me to find a moment to reflect on what I got done today and how did that line up against what my actual to-do list was. And just seeing it on my calendar and knowing
我已经完成了那个会议或者我已经发送了那个产品，这不足以让我获得那种平静或解脱感，或者让焦虑消退。所以在新冠疫情期间，我也开始使用老式的纸笔日历，就像日记一样，写下我需要完成的事情。我着眼于一周，而不是一天。我设定一周的目标，每周日或周一，我重置本周的目标。然后把它们划掉，像任何有待办事项清单的人一样划掉项目。
that I had gotten through that meeting or I had sent along that product, that wasn't enough for me to get that sense of calm or relief for to let the anxiety subside. So in COVID, I started also just using an old school paper and pencil calendar, like a journal, and writing down what I needed to get done. I look at the week. I don't look at the day. I set a goal for the week, and at every Sunday or Monday, I reset my goals for the week. And cross them off, cross the items off, like anybody does when they have a to-do list.
但当一周结束时，我并没有把那一页撕掉扔进垃圾桶，而是把它们都留了下来。每隔一两周，我会翻回去看看一个月前我在尝试做什么？三周前我在尝试做什么？这实际上带来了一种平静感。我很难记住我完成了什么？
But rather than ripping that page off and throwing it in the trash when the week is done, I've kept all of them. And periodically, every one or two weeks, I flip back and I look at a month ago, what was I trying to do? Three weeks ago, what was I trying to do? And that actually brings a sense of calm. It's hard for me to remember what did I get done?
我的目光太短浅了，因为生活现在就是这样要求的。但我确实通过反思一个月前发生的事情获得了一种解脱感、生产力和进步感，对我来说，这似乎确实是通过字面意义上查看我手写的待办事项清单，看到我勾选的所有事情以及我没有完成的事情，并意识到这个比例对我有利而实现的。现在，艾米丽，表面上看，你似乎在建议人们做的事情不仅不同，甚至是相反的。
I am so myopically focused because that's what life is requiring right now. But I do get a sense of relief and productivity and progress by reflecting on what happened a month ago that really for me seems to come by quite literally looking at that to-do list that I wrote down by hand and seeing all the things that I checked off and the things that I didn't get to and realizing that that ratio is tipped in my favor. Now, it can seem on the surface, Emily, that you're advising people to do not just different things, but opposite things.
你不要有狭窄的焦点，那会让你到达终点线，要有宽广的焦点，那实际上会让你对生活有更多的视角。我想你的观点是，不同的视觉技巧在项目的不同阶段，甚至在人生的不同阶段可能都是有价值的。是的，我认为这些是工具箱里的工具。如果我们想盖房子，我们不能只用一把锤子，有时不同的工具更适合不同的工作。当然，我们可以用螺丝刀敲打钉子，它可能会取得一些
You don't have a narrow focus that will get you to the finish line, have a wide focus that will actually give you more perspective on your life. I think your point is that different visual techniques might be valuable at different stages of a project, maybe even at different stages in life. Yeah, I think of these as tools and a toolbox. And if we want to build a house, we can't just use a hammer that sometimes there are different tools that are better for different jobs. Now, of course, we could use a screwdriver and bang against a nail and it might make some
进展，但它可能不是我们最好的工具。因此，通过了解这些技巧，通过练习这些技巧，它创造了一种灵活性，扩展了我们的工具箱，这样我们就可以尝试在工具不适用时更换一个，或者当工作变得更难、工作发生变化，而我们没有取得我们想要的进展时，我们可以把一个工具换成另一个。艾米丽关于目标追求的见解来自于对他人进行的实验，但她也把自己当作了研究对象。
progress, but it might not be the best tool for us. So by being aware of these techniques, by practicing these techniques, it creates a flexibility, expands our toolbox so that we might try trading out one tool when it's not working for us, or when the job gets harder, the job changes, and we're not making the kind of progress that we'd like, we can swap out one tool for another. Emily's insights on goal pursuit have come from running experiments on other people, but she's also treated herself like a research subject.
她使用了她在这里描述的技巧来帮助她学习打鼓。正如你可能记得节目开头提到的，艾米丽有许多不利因素。所以对我来说，学习协调四肢以演奏一首我将为他人表演的曲子将是一个巨大的挑战。这就是我让自己负责的方式。我设定了一个日期，我将有一场演出，一场只有一首歌的演出，而且不会有返场，因为我不知道还能演奏什么，除非他们想再听一遍同一首歌。
She has used the techniques she described here to help her learn to play the drums. As you might remember from the top of the show, Emily had a number of factors working against her. So for me, this was going to be quite a challenge to learn how to coordinate all four limbs in order to play a tune that I was going to perform for others. That's how I made myself accountable. I said a date, and I was going to have a show, a show of one song, and there would be no on-course because I didn't know anything else to play unless they wanted to hear the same song again.
这就是我在书中谈到的，这些是我建议其他人尝试的策略，我在这一年里，也就是我儿子生命的第一年，把它们都用在了自己身上，而这恰好也是我学习这首歌所花费的时间。我不是一个学得快的人。但我做到了。在过程中的不同点，我尝试了其中一些技巧。有些在某些时刻比其他时刻效果更好。它们给我带来了不同的机会。所以我非常真实地写下了我的经历。有时我建议一种策略，然后说，但你知道吗，它在这次实例中实际上对我不起作用。也许我在错误的时间使用了它。也许我使用它的方式不对。但完全披露一下，它可能并不适用于所有人。我认为事实就是，任何人说的任何帮助我们的策略都不会是一个万无一失的解决方案。
And so that's what I talk about in this book is, is these tactics that I suggest others try, I tried them all out on myself across the course of this year, my son's first year of life, and that would happen to be also the same amount of time that it took me in order to learn this song. I wasn't a fast learner. But I got there. And some of these techniques, I tried at different points in the process. Some of them worked better in other moments than others. And they brought different opportunities to me. And so I write quite truthfully about my experience. And sometimes I'm advising one tactic and then saying, but you know what, it actually didn't work for me in this instance. Maybe I used it at the wrong time. Maybe I used it the wrong way. But full disclosure, it may not work for everybody. And I think that's the truth of it is that no one tactic that anybody says to help us along the way is going to be a full proof solution.
来帮助我们，这不会是一个万无一失的解决方案。每个人都是不同的，每个挑战都是不同的。但这是四个策略，它们只是给我们提供了替代方案。如果我们的首选策略不起作用，我们可以尝试其他东西。心理学家艾米丽·巴尔塞蒂斯在纽约大学工作。她是《更清晰、更近、更好：成功人士如何看待世界》一书的作者。艾米丽，感谢你今天参加我们的《隐藏的大脑》节目。谢谢。
to help us along the way is going to be a full proof solution. Every person is different, every challenge is different. But these are four tactics that just give us alternate. Something else that we can try if what our go-to strategy is just isn't working. Psychologist Emily Balcettis works at New York University. She's the author of Cleara Closer Better, How Successful People See The World. Emily, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you.
本集由蕾娜·科恩和珍妮·施密特制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和凯特·希普内克编辑。我们的团队包括帕特·沙、劳拉·夸雷尔和托马斯·刘，工程支持来自尼尔·劳赫。我们本周的无名英雄是艾琳·雷吉斯特。艾琳是NPR编程的项目经理。她使她参与的每一个项目都运行得更顺畅，她这样做时带着善良、同情心和对细节的真正关注。
This episode was produced by Raina Cohen and Jenny Schmitt. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Kat Shipnek. Our team includes Pat Sha, Laura Quarelle and Thomas Liu, engineering support from Neil Rauch. Our unsung hero this week is Erin Register. Erin is a project manager in programming at NPR. She makes every project that she works on run more smoothly, and she does so with kindness, compassion, and a real attention to detail.
非常感谢你，艾琳。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。今天的节目是我们U2.0系列的一部分，该系列贯穿整个月。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请务必与可能喜欢这个系列的朋友分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。我要成为你的宝贝，我要成为你的宝贝，我要成为你的宝贝，我要成为你的宝贝
Thank you so much, Erin. For more Hidden Brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. Today's episode was part of our U2.0 series, which runs all this month. If you liked today's episode, please be sure to share it with a friend who might enjoy this series. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. I'm gonna be your baby, I'm gonna be your baby I'm gonna be your baby, I'm gonna be your baby
我要成为你的宝贝，我要成为你的宝贝。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I'm gonna be your baby, I'm gonna be your baby There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。